Olivia holy repeat after me
hi Olivia
I'll give you Greg
Rachel
sorry I want to be funny if I did
citizens of the reject Nation we're
going to call this segment movies you
can't watch without your wife or else
she'll get mad at you any couple who's
been in a long-term relationship can
relate Hey Olivia misses Alba oh God I
was hoping you wouldn't do that we would
call you vice president no my bad first
lady vice president
I'm learning what political hierarchies
are nothing all in your beer it happens
man jeez you complain when John
disappointed out yeah you've got
something all in your beard
anyway guys we're gonna watch The Little
Mermaid today we love the original one
before we go into any of that something
that we did want to talk about uh Olivia
and I we have four cats ourselves but
within the past month we have been
fostering five additional cats because
we're insane these five cats that we've
been fostering won't go in any details
but uh long story short they came from a
really really bad you know domestically
violent home when taking care of them we
got them properly bathed right ones we
got you know spayed and neutered even
been potty trained lately they're great
uh just really really love them just
right now though you know for these five
cats we gotta you know Siamese once Dash
and Asher Aspen Wren and mama who looks
like the baby but she's really mama and
what's her actual name you're gonna call
her mama this whole time Laura really
really do love them and right now we
have been actively looking for people to
adopt them
um if you can adopt all at least adopt
like one or two of them so there's a
link in the description box and pin
comment for the rescue site you would
have to go through the rescue site in
order to adopt them as much as we love
them just with the space that we have we
know that they deserve a better home
right now a place where they can be
properly cared for and loved if you are
interested or know someone who's
interested please ask and sincerely if
you can spread the word and uh help help
these guys find a home because they
absolutely deserve it and they are
lovely truly lovely animals and we're
gonna miss them
but uh anyway I'm gonna segue us now to
the video at hand leave a like on this
video if you're excited for Little
Mermaid I've heard good and bad things
but we are gonna form our own opinion
and anyone who knows my wife she is
known to be the most brutally honest
person in the world and by the way she
has been vastly instrumental behind the
scenes and ask anyone who comes on this
channel John especially would know she
has helped out behind the scenes
numerous times and plain and simple she
does not get enough credit and I don't
know whose fault that is but they
deserve to be punished yeah this double
truck has a lot to do behind the scenes
okay also full-length reaction watching
long reports where you single with your
own copy of Little Mermaid if you
already have one available for our super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page thank
you to all who have joined and shown
your support but if you have to make a
decision between helping the cats or
joining the patreon help the cats please
let's watch this movie people
it's a gorgeous opening shot I feel like
we're about to hear Neil deGrasse Tyson
narrating this or that one from the BBC
old British guy
the Mermaid has no tears and there
before she suffers so much more
I know a lot of Hans Christian
Anderson's work it sounds like she's
probably suffered
that the original author yeah oh
[Music]
my God
what a horrible
interesting so they're all just they
know they're hunting a mermaid right now
I think they're thinking it's like those
deep sea tales that fishermen and
Pirates tell each other
a mermaid use your eyes
a poor dolphin do not hurt that dolphin
they tell you this is when we see King
calls his will make Jordans together to
learn men to that day it's not what they
say tail
[Music]
we're going home tonight pay attention I
need you to be more careful
Crimson
oh here we go show me what I'm here for
show me the things I know
[Music]
look at these realistic fish that these
overpaid VFX are I was gonna say clearly
it's not real but
okay we know that Disney screws over
their VFX artisan
[Music]
better than the flash hey everything is
better than the flash these days
my man trident
[Music]
keep
a fish Daughters of the Seven Seas I
welcome the news from all of your Waters
oh Halos for good Tamika
and gaspia Indira they're clearly not
all from the same mom is that Jessica
Chastity I don't think so Karina
Rose
cereal Ariel I told you Sebastian says
audio I told you Sebastian
I reminded her about the Gathering just
this morning what Mark I want crustacean
do
yle
he's cute I like him he's adorable you
know
we aren't supposed to be this far from
the palace Ariel let's go back oh
this is a little unsettling
I think we've gone far enough look at
the details on her skin they even have
like little scales that's cool I've
never seen that one
real wait for me you know I can't swim
that fast yeah he's small I know
a small boy he was fat as hell in the
freaking cartoon he was a little chunky
flounder he must have used the ship for
battles or something yeah let's get out
of here getting cold fins no
and you can stay out here and watch the
Sharks all right what I mean he is still
cute he's very cute he's very adorable
when she did a little boo-boo on it I
was like adorable be cool to have a
talking fish I want to poop a fish
[Music]
I'm King flounder Lord
it is very adorable
will he relaxed it's just a reflection
that is great because animals can't tell
their Reflections no
fish are friends not food I know Bruce
no Bruce don't do it would sharks be
afraid of mermaids
I don't know if this happened in the
cartoon so I know it did considering her
father is the king of the ocean
[Music]
hide hide baby flounder hide
yes leave that shark there to die that's
cool too the Sharks can't talk in this
world for some reason so it's just gonna
die down there
what are you doing don't mind me I was
just grabbing a snack that's right they
got Aquafina yeah I forgot any idea what
this is oh oh oh oh it's a dingle hopper
still funny humans use these babies to
style their hair
your father still won't let you go to
the surface huh no it's forbidden he
thinks all humans are are various they
are my name's who's a rock the Gathering
the King Triton's daughters minus one I
thought it was gonna kill me yeah sorry
Scuttle gotta go yeah yeah all right
sweetie I think the Sebastian is
Lafayette from uh Hamilton David Dixon
oh I think so I don't know what a shame
is
to invite Angie Ursula to the party
again
oh this is gonna be a lot sadder in live
action I'll tell you that much
I know look at me
Madness all right Melissa McCarthy doing
doing pretty good I may have finally
found Daddy's weakness an ethnicity of a
woman he hasn't been with yet
[Laughter]
just like your mother I am her daughter
yes foolish enough to be taken with the
human world if you would just try to
understand try to understand you long
enough but as long as you live in my
ocean you'll obey my rules oh a man
we've all had those talks at
authoritative quality I listen to you oh
yeah I would my aerial needs constant
supervision all the time day and night
and you're just a crap to do it I am
just decrypted no wait that's not what
go yes your majesty a lot of things
definitely move better in the actual
film than in the trailer like Sebastian
really just creeped me out in the
trailer but it really looks really looks
really great here yeah I appreciate that
they actually make them a little
animated yeah it's like a good blend
between this is what it looks like in
real life but it's also animated real
life crabs are cute though too they are
[Music]
yeah we're about to get our first song
it's coming up here soon let's do it are
you okay
doesn't even hear me I'm just not like
him I don't see things the way he does
now you're just as stubborn in some ways
this is what I'm here for let's go let's
go
isn't it neat you bet wouldn't you think
my collection never it's never complete
wouldn't you think I'm the girl the girl
who has everything you are the King's
Daughter so yes
how many wonders can one Cavern hold you
could fit more in there sure
she's got everything I've got gadgets
and gizmos are plenty I've got a who's
that said what's its Galore her voice is
incredible
I want my
nipple chills man
I wanna see wanna see him dancing
walking around
oh
fear gross
God the pipes on her
to explore that you're above us
oh there's like Goosebumps I don't know
there's so much emotion behind this
[Music]
that's phenomenal man that was amazing
tear it up a little bit dude
because she's not just hitting like the
notes like she's really capturing the
actual emotions yeah that desperate
wanting oh no no no what does she think
she doing
surface
oh
she just at the Disneyland show
Mickey Mouse is on that though yeah
Ariel
[Music]
oh no how'd she get up there upper body
strength apparently Jesus she does upper
body dates every day she's got water
weights under there
this time you separated yourself from
the rest of the crew these peasants are
more becoming of a future king you mean
be more like my father was cut off from
the rest of the world I relate with this
guy
21 years ago the king and queen took you
in and treated you as one of their own
so he's not an actual Heir is that
what's Happening Here
it's a kind of leader that's the whole
reason we're on this voice don't you see
we have to stay open to what's out here
that's the only way our Island can grow
I want to make England Great again how
do they not see her shiny fins how she
not flopping around like a fish does
when they're out of water for a while
damn that hit quick didn't it I do like
how they have enhanced the grittiness I
guess of the Sailor life feels like
Pirates of the Caribbean I think it
works really well live action-wise
actually yeah
I would have completely panicked and
given up at this point yeah
yeah we're dead
that guy's dead
[Music]
oh no we need water
I am a sucker for something that feels
like it's on a Sound Stage I do like it
the vibe of that
hug
[Music]
second I saw someone stopped to save a
dog me too
[Music]
I'm so confused me what I thought that
was happening in the movie
you get knocked out is that what
happened when his head bashed against
the I want this movie to subvert
expectations she shouldn't bomb him oh
my God the dark Little Mermaid
here
well they look good together they do
she's more like her dad than she
realizes that's the whole point of the
movie I'm talking about the interracial
love oh my gosh
get off me you fool oh hey didn't expect
to find you here the king can never hear
this why would she talk to the king I'm
going to forget this ever happened
are you listening to me yes sir
that was funny
what would I do just
smiling at me
I can't get over your interracial love
joke
[Music]
why do they have torches it's not dark
out nah maybe they were searching
through the night he's alive I let the
queen
[Music]
I I got my eyes on you you just want to
turn everything into like a horror movie
so creepy suck text happening I don't
know how but I know something's starting
right now
you tell me this is a bit of a horror
movie
[Music]
here we go
beautiful
in love with the human world and now she
found her soul mate
finally
the power away from Triton that should
have been mine all alone why should it
have been hers looks a little bit like
cosplay I think she's doing a great job
but I feel like her makeup animated did
you see Ursula in the film and yeah but
no one else looks like cosplay but she
kind of looks a little bit like I think
she's doing a great performance she had
like super heavy makeup in the film in
the animated film I agree I can still
feel they could be both
you're wrong and I'm right
swear that's where you sign up for oh
yeah tie the knot
this obsession with humans
maybe crusty Sebastian if you had just
seen it up there the ship rode on the
wind and they filled the sky with fire
okay okay listen to me
[Music]
better than anything they got going on
up there yep let's hear this sweet is
always greener in somebody else's League
oh Shame about going up there but that
is a big mistake right here on the ocean
floor
wonderful things surround you what more
is your
[Music]
the place
under the sea
oh how beautiful that's cool nobody beat
us and eat us oh
[Music]
so they can touch the jellyfish I feel
like this is the first time I'm really
paying attention to the lyrics
I didn't realize they say fry has to
feed us that's why I was like I've sung
along with this but I don't think I
caught that contest
oh so cute that's more like the size of
flounder oh look how cute
look at them
like little flubbers yeah
[Music]
oh that's really cool do you think her
holding on to them like that is hurting
them though that's what I was wondering
earlier
know how to jam here
very beautiful they all gathered to
teach Ariel I was gonna say they've been
missing for a lot of this movie but
suddenly we
she was real she saved my life have you
checked the neighboring Islands not all
of them then I will no you will not I
hope there's a line in there like you
remind me of my mother only you say that
only during our vows oh God
shipwrecks hurricanes the Sea Gods are
against us how many times do I have to
oh he was adopted I forgot yeah
may I remind you that a deadly shipwreck
first brought you to us and now I almost
lost you to one the other day shipwreck
brings you a baby brings you love so
they all in this film like are under
this heavy belief that there are Gods
under the ocean
it's okay Eric
I wonder if they give him a song He's
not Harry Styles so I doubt it I'm
waiting for the new song I think if
Harry Styles it took him
soon let's hear this
now all I am is haunted it's days and
hours Rojo by all I ever think about is
you
in these wild uncharted waters come find
me you deep Eric you deep
[Music]
a siren
this guy has been singing since we were
not sure
jeez we've been sailing for hours
my God damn
these two have Odes
extremely passionate love for each other
I am wasn't she blurry when he saw her
so he doesn't really know what she looks
like that's the whole point of but the
reality is stuck in his head nobody
mentioned her eyes you saw a little bit
of her eyes what color are my eyes gray
there are some type of green brownish
blue thing
it will take thousands of years for this
Coral to grow back and they've killed
nearly all of this
I've never even seen one you were just a
child when mother died and father
stopped there they all have the same
mother they all have the same mother I
don't understand how the reproduction of
the children
have you noticed that Ariel has been
acting peculiar lately I know you've
been keeping something from it keeping
something
is my little one in love
oh I tried to stop us I tried to stop
her from going to the service I started
to stay away from humans
oh no Sebastian he got scared he was
scared
you went to the above World there was a
shipwreck a man was drowning I had to
save him you should have let him Drown
Your savages savages savages and even
humans
Eric had nothing to do with it Eric you
know his
you would have just heard him father
he's he's passionate and kind he's a
human you're a mermaid yes but that
doesn't make us enemies promise me we'll
never look for him again damn these are
like real ass performances
oh man you really feel the emotion much
more like action
leave again I feel like in the animated
that scene was more impactful for some
reason her reaction like the facial
expressions is like this is way more
because of the tangibility because it's
real life yeah
[Music]
I mean the one part as a viewer that I'm
having a hard time working passes I'm I
was more used to trying being like
someone I was like he's scary and he's
not really scary here he seems more
father-like here yeah yeah he's more
compassionate and yeah he's a little
softer yeah my mind's just readjusting
I'm your auntie Ursula the sea witch the
what
Sunday morning
whatever you say darling
darling wait yes
[Music]
careful
whoa there's like prehistoric stuff
Happening Here same at all like father
described you he always got what he
wanted and what did I get nothing
I know what you're going to believe me I
know why you're here I really like her
yeah she's doing great and you're so
young don't you see you're meant for
each other
you suffer like this
love the theatrical tortured performance
she's doing great you can't live in that
world unless you become a human yourself
did the whole performance it's not even
possible it's what I do
that's what I live that's what I live
for I admit that in the past I've been a
nasty
I've landed all my ways repentance in
the light and let us switch through yes
fortunately she's a little magic
into magic and you lately please don't
laugh I use it on behalf of the
miserable lonely and depressed pathetic
[Music]
this one Longing To Be thinner that one
wants to give the girl and do I help him
yes indeed
I was not expecting her to be this good
I wasn't either I'll whip up a little
potion to make you human for three days
I would sleep all three of those
before the sun sets on the third day you
and princy must share a kiss you will
remain human permanently but a few jokes
you'll turn back into a mermaid give up
the whole sea life give up your mermaid
gifts you won't have the stereos hanging
around dragging you down you won't be
able to breathe in the water who needs
it
I really think she's one of the best
performances so far you'll no longer
have that Sirens song
so it is like a siren I'll keep it safe
and soundness here with me we got a deal
I don't know I mean I'll just give you
the premium package kid
I mean they're they're both like really
great in this movie
[Music]
damn that is visually stunning
just your voice
volume and your soul
to me
[Applause]
[Music]
this thing terrified me when I was a kid
this is pretty terrifying yeah I don't
know how she was like
[Music]
I was gonna say she just drowns and dies
it's interesting that she knew to use
her feet well isn't it the same way a
tail works I guess
he was like
well you still have to kind of like feed
her
well don't say motion essentially right
let me go after the mermaid I know she
doesn't stand a chance
without this a mermaid without a voice
you know what they cut out the alt-right
um fear Monger body language which is
like how can I get him
when they're like you have your looks
your pretty face they cut that out she
won't remember she needs to get I don't
know why I like that part it's just a
matter of time
I feel like Melissa McCarthy like
there's something in her performance of
her eyes where she's she's not overly
animated here that makes like she keeps
it really cold here it's like a perfect
pitch for the performance
girl are you all right I'll go find
something to cover you up
I need I need to close up our feet here
okay I'll take you to the castle they'll
know what to do with you there come on
it's gonna get cooked oh yeah the chef's
in well they cut them up that weird
little shop with a little Thin Mustache
this feels different
really seen like the Caribbean fisherman
life
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about having
this song kind of loses the effect that
she's supposed to feel like she doesn't
have a voice she'll survive but she's
been through it I wonder what happened
to her dear look it's a fire it's warm
and it glows and it lights this chamber
I actually like it because I feel like
this is how she would behave these are
things she's all wanted to see but I
think we could have done it without a
song
then how will we know what she's
thinking
come on Ariel time to stop
there you go
all of your poor girl you must be
starving Rosa get us for a child some
food everyone's so sympathetic to her
odd behaviors I know oh adorable
two shipwrecks in one week Prince Eric's
still looking for that girl who saved
him let's do your idea I'll get the
prince
see they put it together because she's
singing yeah in her mind
like you know
I'm so sorry to hear what happened
what's your name she doesn't speak sire
get rid of her the woman I loved said
well we're glad you made it to us see a
place to stay you saw her whole outline
right well then you're welcome to stay
here make sure she has anything she
needs
and Earl you could have swam to a very
different Shore things could have turned
out very different for you
we should let you get some rest
I guess the song works on the sense of
the gut punch of the build up she's like
oh he's gonna know it's me I know God
all right I'll try to help you but we've
got to be bold act quickly don't forget
about the case
no no not me the prince
hello
oh no she's Put a Spell on You you can't
remember can you
[Music]
I mean you saw her Put A Spell On
hopeless child yes I knew it
that's all I would do so she's a
princess under the sea gets shot to be
human to become a princess on life just
put that together flounder told me the
whole story as Ariel killed the Prince
yet
straight face where's Ariel now what do
you mean she's right here
she moves so fast without him noticing
she's in his room doesn't even know it
[Music]
well they really needed to find the
actress who could yeah who can sing to
dialogue and be able to communicate just
with her eyes like Expressions so well
nobody usually comes in here
my Little Mermaid
oh so cute
he said the title of the Moon
I never believed all that law about
mermaids luring Sailors to their deaths
oh really I want you to have her nearly
all of these things come from my voyages
you're both Hoarders
perfect you believe that such amazing
things exist down there
no wait
he knows even more oh that's smart
that's smart I don't remember if that's
in the anime movie or not regardless
that is smart there's loads of them at
this time of year
had no idea you could do that oh me
no that's really clever is this the
anime movie I remember how do I
yeah that's it that's it
[Music]
I'll work on that
I love the people there oh we've been
together for hours it's so cute yeah
she's just been listening to him talk
the whole time
so funny you're the perfect woman
you listen so wow
and then all of that is Rainforest I
could show you around
all right we'll go tomorrow but so oh
Grimsby good may I have a quiet word sir
quiet word it's interesting how they've
made Grimms be a bit of a Grimmer I like
he's a bit of a not an antagonist but an
obstacle or something like that you know
we were going to send out all the
characters tomorrow to look for the girl
of course yes we must do that what your
mother said yesterday about you not
leaving the castle until you're feeling
better I feel fine it feels fine Grimsby
we gotta do this
I suppose we could spare one Carriage ah
never mind this one I thought Grimsby
was about this was smooth you just
cursed sorry use the curse word
[Music]
are we not going to get a scene of the
the cooking oh you're right I guess so
we're running low on time for that
young lady
I think you'll be needing this hey is
that the original uh Ariel is it uh
what's her name
Amy Ashley
I don't know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh look at Eric culturally acquainted
with his people you'll see the eyes of a
screech out up in the tree hey hey
[Music]
my oh my I think it's time for a little
vocal romantic stimulation please know
nah man we got to be sneaky about this
using the power of suggestion how are we
gonna do that we've got to blend in with
the sounds of nature so she doesn't hear
us they really done flounder dirty
a lot of character really
[Music]
words she don't got a lot to say but
there's something about her
crap
[Laughter]
the time is right and the time is
tonight go on and kisses
Jungle Cruise
[Music]
[Laughter]
Catherine no definitely not Catherine
Aries close Aries
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was clever I like that that was
really cute that's a beautiful leg
Written in the Stars oh
so cute together
kiss my girl foreign
[Music]
look at him Slither away
it's not fair Ursula it's time Ursula
took matters into her own sense oh here
we go
oh yeah I wonder what she's gonna look
like
oh
[Laughter]
that prince won't know
the most Melissa McCarthy moment
she's not in this water look again
shirts all of a sudden says if you have
to Ariel wouldn't dare go above no idea
why would she leave never mind that just
find her uh did you guys don't need to
know why should we continue the search I
feel a little if you want the advice of
an old man don't be held back by what
you think should be I think only of what
is I'm still single Eric
why would I listen to you
[Music]
dilemma Eric
do I hold out for that one person who I
saw a blurry moment of or this one I've
had a connection with all day with it's
hard choices man the scales what if the
other one's hotter
[Music]
whoa
damn
Melissa McCarthy you really did a lot
for this
who is that actress I don't know she's
beautiful that is a hard competition now
man wake up wake up wake up wake up once
I know who wrote this song
then I can fly in here for you to see
and hear what I found oh my God is this
100 to the rhythm of this yeah
he wants to you know when humans oh man
they're Penguins throw rice for the
pigeons they're trying to blow up the
pigeons
so we can't slow down
thank you thank you either you and I
feel very different about that
not into that song I thought it was fun
right the surprise Eric but I do owe her
my life this evening you shall introduce
your intended to the court if it's
really what you want Eric what I
want
um
it's what we both want
lovely indeed okay so he is like
Enchanted under a spell right now look
at the movie didn't make it clear if
they were doing that the voice also has
like a siren hold on them Ariel
[Laughter]
[Music]
the girl that cast doesn't look evil I
remember in the animated movie I know
yeah
[Music]
how do you cast a girl that looks evil
she's a green I know a few
[Music]
it's like living in a reality show Ariel
I'm sorry I know it was her but it
wasn't
she's she's funny see which in Disguise
yes yo gold flounder go tell the Sea
King what's happening oh oh no when I
give these signal you dropped me got it
got it
guess I'm on my own
oh Eric it's beautiful
[Applause]
has anybody seen the ring
[Music]
yes scrimsby
right
kill her Peck her face
[Music]
oh I kind of feel like they rushed to
this one I mean yeah I think we're
trying to get to the climax here
oh you want to see more of a girl fight
no I just be like a total because I move
a little fast through it
[Music]
oh yeah they're real
Ariel
I see you all alone
I should have known I don't know what
came on for me
get away from her whoa that was kind of
scary
[Music]
oh okay she plays Evil well
she belongs to me now
blood it's unbreakable I want to see you
suffer for unfortunate soul unfortunate
soul
[Music]
wow
so all of his powers in the
oh my God it's turning into The Little
Mermaid tiny things yeah a little worm
[Music]
s
how did we get so far down
[Music]
oh
oh my
they didn't deserve that
she's misunderstood
there's two sides for every story
holy moly they did it
this feels a lot of crafting
[Music]
oh they were in her hair
oh my
God damn that's pretty terrify that was
great
[Music]
she's really doubling down to kill these
two
[Music]
oh my
what is she doing she helped guide the
boat I was thinking is it did she push
it up and how I I don't know
he's not even gonna try to jump out of
the way
oh
damn Ursula your response time is really
slow
basketball players are slow
she's like giant size there's a
difference okay
Daddy trident's back I didn't fight
alone father Eric was with me well done
letters knows that you're safe
on a home where you belong you can at
least get Eric to shore
oh Eric's gonna do it all down yeah
[Laughter]
actually after a fantasy guy no I was
wrong she was very real and so were your
feelings for her I see that now it's
just that I really like this to freaking
Edition
to be together I actually really like
almost everything that's been added
Eric's buried someone else he's got
children she's a real abandoned
[Laughter]
it was weird about sure he doesn't have
the blurring effect as the water
provides then there's just one problem
left
thank you
[Music]
oh he's crying yeah it's pretty sad
oh
Ah that's some touch and crap right
there
[Music]
speed
[Applause]
wait till they meet your father-in-law
the old marriage marks A New Beginning
for us the beginning the royalty trades
we can conduct later on
something you almost lost where where is
it you're sitting on it bird
oh keep it from me
I hope she causes you less trouble than
I did you won't be gone too long
were you Ariel oh that's right she loses
her best friend
[Music]
to give up your remorse to be heard well
now I am listening and I will always be
here for you
[Music]
damn that cut one
where's that crazy guy
has been destroyed
[Music]
it was perfect
[Laughter]
yep there you go
new lyrics by new lyrics by all right
okay okay you know what I was thinking
about me we kind of like we commented a
lot during the movie what I was thinking
though of what I why I liked Haley
Bailey's performance so much especially
underwater is
when she interacts with the other
animals
is there another word for underwater
animals uh
sea life when she interacts with the sea
life
it feels like she's really interacting
with another character she's not just
like hey I'm pretending like I'm talking
to a green screen thing right now we're
a tennis ball it really seems like she's
she's having a real scene so that
there's like a genuineness to it and I
thought I thought she was uh I thought
she was perfect
what did you think I thought I think all
the characters are perfect honestly I
don't think anyone was like miscast or
didn't fit their roles
um yeah I really loved her performance
her emotion behind a lot of the songs I
feel was something that isn't really
portrayed in something animated
because you don't get
that emotion on a face
um
and even Javier verdem's performance I
feel like I buy
the father-daughter role here I'm more
connected to it even though I don't have
a relationship with my dad a more
emotionally connected to it than in the
animated film
I think all the relationships are
fleshed out better here than in the
animated film
that's fair
that's it's also what much longer than
the animated film now right
yeah I had more time I mean I'm taking
this off look guys I know you I know
people say
there's there's always those inevitable
comments where people someone's gonna
come in and be like you should just look
at it on its own without comparing to
the animated movie but that's impossible
that's a big ask that you were asking of
someone to like completely limited
something you've watched repetitively
throughout your childhood and look at
this stable of your child when they have
like adapted certain so much of it like
scene to scene it's impossible to do
that I don't think this replaces the
animated film I feel like if I ever have
a child I I show them the animated film
first before I show them this because I
am so deeply connected
to the animated film from my childhood
uh-huh
um I I it's you're gonna get the
comparisons you can't look at it as it's
on it's the same story it's the same
story there's a lot of his Shopper shots
because they're they're adapting the
animated movie Jody Benson that's the
original Ariel and I just saw her okay I
kept saying Amy or Ashley Jody Benson I
I I agree I think there's there I was
the thing that surprised me was there
are some things that I I actually
thought they did better like with
certain relationships
I do think it's still a little too long
am I I think it's a little like it goes
on a little too long there's when he's
out by the Sea and I thought he was
looking at Vanessa that's when I started
feeling the length at one point I almost
like June said I feel like this is
running a little bit Yeah it goes a
little too long and uh I I don't and
while I find like Sebastian cute and
like I think the designs of them are
cute and I and Aquafina surprised me I'm
see there's something about Aquafina
where every time she shows up in
something I like her a lot but for some
reason my initial uh preconceived a
hater for some reason but every time she
shows up at anything I'm always like
she's great and this is another case of
that where I'm like I I don't know why I
doubt that I'm going to enjoy her
performances because yeah I thought she
was excellent I like how she she played
her more aloof than uh even the animated
version I still the thing is I with the
animated version I prefer the
it's kind of horrible because it's an
animated movie and it and again this is
my first time watching this movie versus
repetitively watching the animated movie
the the the animal the the sea life and
the animals are I like significantly
more in the animated version and uh like
like Sebastian in him in as a character
or Sebastian I like more I feel more of
that energy interesting I like Sebastian
better here but for you yeah what that
shocks me I prefer flounder in the
animated film he's more oh a thousand
percent I don't think there's there's no
disputing that and I prefer Scuttle if
you prefer if you prefer floundery in
these than this I don't I have no idea
I can't even see an argument for that
yeah
because he's like that relationship
feels almost non-existent here I feel
like Sebastian has more um
relatable qualities here than the
animated crap
how well do you remember
Sebastian because I remember Sebastian
he's more of like um
from how I remember it you've seen the
movie the animated film more recently
than I have
I mean I've known it really well and
then I saw it a few months ago yeah
before the one of the trailers yeah yeah
um
whereas
I I remember Sebastian being kind of
like really staunch on the rules like
uh don't do this he was kind of more he
wasn't as lenient as the Sebastian here
if that makes sense that's what I
remember I think I think I still have
more of a connect because of the fact
that it's animated they allow more
expression and teeth and stuff and I
thought he was really funny in the
animated so yeah I still I think my
because yeah I mean he's significantly
more fresh and he's kind of like an
iconic side character yeah well they've
cut out one of the most iconic scenes
from the film with Sebastian which was
the chef scene yeah yeah so I I have I
have that preference there and I'm just
getting the comparison stuff out of the
way
and uh yeah I mean like there's not
dude it's it's tough because it's such a
different medium that I there's there
feels like just because of the nature of
what we do that you have to pick but I
I'm not no I I I there I just go this
one's different and then here's what I
like and here's what I don't like I I
like I was surprised by how much I
actually enjoyed this because I love the
first trailer and the second trailer I
did not like and then this TR this movie
was Oh this is actually really enjoyable
take the animated film out of it this on
its own Standalone is a good film they
do manage to make it their own as well
without it just being one of those only
solely just a one-to-one adaptation that
they I thought they added enough and
then the way they adapted the the
sequences that were directly from the
animated movie I feel like they did add
their own flavor around it and the
performances didn't feel just derivative
of them like trying to copy paste yeah I
think Javier Bardem especially does a
very different Trident
um and a Haley Bailey Triton Trident
I've been saying Trident my whole life
for the same name
yeah because you know it the the Regal
qualities of of the animated version are
like
you know and and every time he's on
screen and there's there's more of a
of a Pizzazz or something to the to the
because it's animated they could do a
lot more with a limited with a limited
run time where here they needed stuff to
breathe more to get the believability
down you know like all those scenes that
are added between Eric and Ariel uh
I feel like are necessary to them like I
buy into their relationship much more
whereas an animated film that quick fall
in love thing is more believable in an
animated film than it is in a live
action film yes but because of the run
time the excitement and the the Peril of
the stuff in the finale actually to me
yeah it feels a little bit diluted I
agree here because it even even though
the anime movie is like significantly
shorter when Ursula takes over uh in the
human form I feel like for some reason
in the anime movie The it probably
doesn't but it feels like it it lasts
longer and it feels like it's just such
an impact where here it felt like she
took over for like five minutes like 10
minutes you know and then you don't even
see the impact really Triton what
disappears but he's not turned into like
the little worm we don't see him in like
the cage and and you know his struggle
there it's a real real quick
turn around where he's suddenly back
again yeah exactly and and it's and like
I said in the animated movie I mean it's
if for all for all we know it's probably
the same amount of run time but the
effect still manages to have much more
of an impact and a punch because of that
movie's shorter run time and the energy
and the pacing how much they could do a
lot more with a little run time because
animated they can rely more on the
emotion being conveyed with visual
expression uh than than here so yeah
because of the way this movie's paced by
the time you get to these parts that
actually feels rushed and and the the
weight of it feels like kind of kind of
dimmed down
um because it's like they were barely he
was barely if you're here because of the
run time it feels like Trident was
barely gone you know he's gone for like
a few minutes his sacrifice only lasted
a few minutes yeah
um Ursula taking over in the human form
was only a few minutes where before it
was like wow it really feels like All Is
Lost in Ariel can't conquer this so yeah
they did feel rushed there and the but
but really you know
um
I was surprised by how much I really
loved the the relationships everyone I
do actually I gotta say like I I I like
I think I like Ariel and Eric here more
you know I love the cartoony performance
of Eric that classic classic Prince yeah
the classic Charming Prince but their
relationship here was significantly more
nuanced and I have to say as someone who
I feel like Disney movies and a lot of
animated films are trying to take out
that
how do I order this
I'm trying to take out that romance
Factor where oh the woman only cares
about falling in love and true love's
kiss I actually like that they really
leaned heavy into the romance Factor
here and that they are true love and and
gave and meant to be instead of
um like oh she figures it out on her own
and didn't need
Eric to kind of save the day type of
deal I agree well in the animated movie
you know it's it kind of is like they're
both just so freaking perfectly hot
and look at him and they look at her
they fall in love
yeah we're here you watch the
relationship develop yeah and you really
get to see how without I mean he gets to
communicate but through but there's ways
of where the communication is obviously
um uh limited but you still get to see
how they get a bond with each other you
know the words are limited the
interactions the body language and the
the facial expressions are so deeper
here
yeah I think for the human for the I
think yeah for the adaptation of the
human stuff a lot of that works better
yeah
um and that's gonna be I mean it's
pretty normal yeah and so and it had it
but reason like other than like the last
half hour where I thought the pacing was
kind of like dipping a little bit I feel
like the movie was actually paced really
well yeah
um it was really fun like I If we have a
counter here because we're recording a
bunch of equipment stuff and then by the
time I got to the airport I was like oh
wow we're an hour like I didn't realize
how much time had gone by
and and I normally if I see that counter
I'm I'm like man we still got this much
time to go that's the only time I looked
down at it is for that scene I was
telling you that I started feeling it
felt like it was running long and I
looked down I was like oh well okay yeah
that was like it was after two hours at
that point but I was like that's when I
felt the length of the film and the
visuals is I like what they did here
more than the choice with Lion King
where they went just like a photo
completely photorealistic in Lion King
they I thought they had a decent splice
of animated meets photorealistic you
know allowing for Sebastian to be more
expressive with his eyes at least and
scutler
Scuttle and flanham terrible names you
know this I know and I've flounder just
watch them I still will butcher it I
promise I will still call her Arya and
um yeah I thought all that was really
rock solid and the musical number what
do you think of the musical I mean the
actual music numbers were as great as
always I think Haley Bailey's voice is
absolutely phenomenalized we've clearly
stated while watching this but
the new ones I don't feel a lot of them
I don't feel unnecessary except for
Ariels I feel like all of her new ones
are fairly necessary but like I don't
care about Prince Eric's singing part
really I don't
um and I didn't like the scuttlebutt
song because it's just so
with the tone of the movie and the other
songs that are in the movie even the
newer songs it was super out of place to
me so it kind of took me out of it a
little bit
all right and I'm like of course you're
gonna have Aquafina I can't I can't I
cannot
disagree with you
because you're scared all I'll say is no
I don't say I was just like
I don't know like this is so odd and it
feels it feels a little out of place but
I don't know for some reason I'm
enjoying I think it's just because I
like my mom all Miranda and I think
Disney obviously loves the Manuel
Miranda honestly hey Lynn we got a new
movie you want to do it again and do
that no problem when it when the song
comes on and you're like this is
obviously lin-manuel Miranda song
it should organically Fitness it took a
few sentences to be like this sounds
exactly like what Le Manuel Miranda does
yeah every single time
um yeah I know it didn't feel like it's
most inventive one I I still
yeah I mean I'm a bit I have a bit of a
dichotomy when it comes to the uh the
one with her inner voice singing stuff
because
you like the scuttlebutt song yeah color
would be weird uh I like the
I don't know I like the I like this song
itself that's the thing is I like the
song itself I think though for the
context of the movie
I I really it pulls me out because I
want to just be in the perspective of
she cannot speak but
but I had some vocal cord malfunction
right now I know what I sound like I
know what I sound like and I think my
thoughts in my voice
of course no I get what you're saying
like I think there's an argument to be
made like we were saying of how you can
still justify it and and I totally see
the choice for that to me though it I
just I feel like the impact is not as
strong the that's my opinion and you
know you have your payments I'm sure
most people probably agree with you
you'd be surprised especially with your
audience uh the Eric song was uh yeah I
was like I feel like I couldn't just use
dialogue here
yeah I didn't like it I don't think we
needed that I didn't think we needed a
whole song he's got a nice voice
um I don't think we need a whole song
though and I yeah I like Derek's
performance a lot and I think they made
him a little bit more you know he's a
lot more swashbuckling in the animated
movie and here he's more of a relatable
guy and I thought to also make them
their his backstory somehow be relatable
I feel so sorry for this princess
poor Guys these royalty struggles huh
but I love the but I thought they made
it um just to make their backgrounds
find a way to truly find a common ground
and similarities where they could
identify with each other I thought was
really strong the addition of the mom I
thought was great uh as well I like it I
also like I feel like it's such a Trope
a cliche of our worlds don't belong
oh it's just such a Trope it was just
such a cliche decision to go with but it
doesn't take me out of the film yeah
something I would like to see not be the
fallback for a lot of films which I feel
like it is I think the anime movie is
like a solid tight film like I say only
80 minutes long that's so the animated
one who's is this
um it's Tara Roxy's one of them they
leave all the time
Tara Roxy we're gonna have a discussion
tonight
um
then there's that what's the other
someone Miss Melissa McCarthy
she disappears totally at the end too
though like she's defeated and you don't
really see that's the Adam made a movie
well
I feel like there should be some impact
from what she's done you know but
especially with the long run time you
have you could have included something
and I'm so used to Disney now the these
days
humanizing their villains a little more
like what they did with
um
Maleficent you know they tend to try to
humanize to make you feel a little bit
more they don't do that at all here with
Ursula
no I I thought to keep her though the
animated one I think Melissa McCarthy
really saves it because she managed to
because I thought it would be the most
cartoony performance and it already
really is out of the universe like it is
um it's the yet she the most can't be
out of all of them yeah she still
managed to not pull like I didn't get
pulled out by her I got more pulled in
because of her she's super engaging yeah
because I thought she was going to be
like way too animated doing her in her
expressions and stuff I thought she was
gonna overdo it and I thought she was
gonna bring too much of that Melissa
because when we heard she was catch
you're like of course of course Melissa
McCarthy's planners like it was just
like the most obvious casting and
despite it being obvious casting she
still managed to honor the animated
version and really bring her unstable to
it and she there's something really
unique
um I got a letter in
Tara yeah
I can let her in from the my phone all
right do it yo we're letting you in you
we're gonna tell you when it's unlocked
is it unlocked oh yeah it's come on in
we're just filming this thing we could
just stand up to go get you we need to
determine if this hair clip is yours
that's leaving behind little hair clips
watch the swearing
okay there's rocks which is our
detective advice and narrowed it down
now she leaves like cups
people always leave crap behind Coy left
a shirt
why is he sure yeah right
there's something about her ex I kept I
couldn't quite pinpoint it like
she kept this like cold stare like a
mouth above and and didn't emote much
here which I thought weirdly grounded
the performance in this large makeup
helps with that though yeah it was like
she got overly botoxed or something and
that she couldn't emote or something but
it worked it it helped it it plays to
that like
um
uh what is that the word for like that
person who's that old-time Starlet who
like used to be used to be the
successful Hollywood Starlet and then
they're now like I'm ready for my
close-upness
yeah she's like that kind of character
golden Hollywood actress yeah exactly a
faded star and that's the kind of
performance that she leaned into here
which I thought was so excellent um yeah
that was perfect
uh yeah visual effects were good I love
this movie I think it's really good I
think it's fun I liked it a lot we do I
love it yeah okay
I mean yeah that's a good movie I'd
watch it again
yeah I would too we own it now so yeah
you can watch it whatever you want good
way to Disney plus but that's fine nope
not for them
I would buy it and I I gotta say too
yeah like uh for
the last thing I'll say
intentionally
with everything going on that this is
the like oftentimes these live action
remakes get a lot of crap for just the
like just like essentially just aping
the script that came before and I think
that for an adaptation script they did a
really great job here uh to it to adapt
it I thought the writing actually did a
really surprisingly good job a lot of
times you just feel like hack jobs and
this did not feel that way to me that
was good acting's good so I got paid
them fairly mother effers
anywho you done yeah you guys want to
buy a cat not this one not these but
there's uh I mean they don't have to buy
right is it is it a buy adoption fee
yeah adoption fee yeah what people can
just get free cash and feed them to
their dogs or their snakes
so who feeds cats that are dogs people
do that yes they use them as like bait
for like fighting dogs yeah
that's horrible yeah all right guys well
we're gonna watch Avatar the way of
water and Aquaman now all right we'll
talk with you guys soon thank you so
much for being here
[Music]